[Aplausos]
[Música]
2020 avanza con la misma rapidez con la
que se expande el coronavirus
[Música]
el 3 de noviembre está cada vez más
cerca y eso eso significa que se acerca
en las elecciones de los eeuu amigos ir
a las urnas tras el primer mandato de un
presidente es siempre algo así como una
especie de referéndum sobre como lo está
haciendo la administración actual pero
es que si además en este caso tenemos en
cuenta el enorme protagonismo que ha
tenido durante este mandato el actual
inquilino de la casa blanca entonces nos
encontramos con que estas elecciones
prometen ser todo un referéndum en torno
a la figura de donald trump y queridos
amigos de visual político donald trump
está en uno de los peores momentos como
presidente afronta una pandemia con más
de 150.000 muertos con dificultades
económicas para millones de personas que
han perdido su empleo y con las calles
llenas de multitudinarias protestas
raciales por un motivo o por otro lo que
es un hecho es que el final de su
mandato está siendo peor de lo que
cualquiera hubiera imaginado
[Música]
así que visto lo visto creo que es hora
de echar un vistazo a la alternativa ver
que ofrece el partido demócrata y su
candidato presidencial
josep rovira baiden juniors más conocido
como joe biden amigos el antiguo
vicepresidente de goma parece una
apuesta por la moderación una apuesta
por la estabilidad pero quién es
exactamente yo byd en cuanto iba en
política que es exactamente lo que
defiende y lo que es más importante que
puede aportar a los eeuu en visual
política en este vídeo vamos a dar
respuesta a todas estas preguntas pero
antes antes vamos a echar la vista atrás
y ver un poco de historia toda la vida
en la política de vdm es natural de
scranton pensilvania una pequeña ciudad
super aburrida que se hizo famosa por
ser escenario de la genial serie the
office si no lo habéis visto apunta blah
el caso amigos es que yo bailé en es el
ejemplo perfecto de lo que es ser todo
un profesional de la política se dice
que ya cuando era un bebé no lloraba
sino que daba directamente discursos y
esquís y bernie sanders yo a media vida
en política
byd él nos supera con creces antes de
ser vicepresidente fue senador por el
estado de delaware durante
ni más ni menos que 36 años para que os
hagáis una idea se estrenó en el cargo
prácticamente tras celebrar su 30
cumpleaños que por cierto es la edad
mínima requerida para ser senador en los
eeuu y amigos desde que se estrenó en el
cargo ya no lo abandonó hasta el 2009
cuando pasó a ser el vicepresidente de
obama durante sus ocho años en la casa
blanca
you by the nació en 1942 un tiempo en el
que se estaban librando en el mundo
batallas como guadalcanal u stalingrado
fue el primogénito de una familia
católica de origen irlandés y cuando yo
apenas tenía diez años la familia baiden
buscó mejorar su situación económica
mudándose a clay mont una localidad
situada en delaware donde yo completó
sus estudios antes de ir a la
universidad un lugar en el que a bailén
se pasó prácticamente toda la década de
los 60 primero hizo un doble grado en
historia y ciencias políticas en la
universidad de delaware y después
derecho la universidad de siracusa
y claro vamos a ver si nos creemos los
estereotipos y sumamos la vida
universitaria y sus orígenes irlandeses
podríamos tal vez imaginarnos a un joven
bailén viviendo unas juergas desenfreno
bañadas en alcohol verdad pues no va a
ser que no porque bailen no bebe cosa
que celebramos pero que bueno tampoco es
garantía de nada eeuu tendrá un
presidente abstemios sea donald trump o
joe biden el caso es que en 1969 tras su
etapa universitaria bailén comenzó a
trabajar como abogado prácticamente al
mismo tiempo que también inició su
actividad política en el partido
demócrata como miembro del consejo del
condado de newcastle hablamos del año
1970 este fue su primer paso antes de
lanzar su candidatura al senado apenas
dos años más tarde en las elecciones del
eran tiempos malos para el partido
demócrata pero el joven bailén logró lo
imposible arrebatar el puesto un senador
republicano muy experimentado en un
momento en el que richard nixon arrasaba
en las elecciones presidenciales no es
un académico no es un pensador teórico
es una encuesta andante viene de una
gran familia trabajadora de scranton
vendedores de coches concesionarios
gente que sabe cómo hacer una venta
bardem tiene ese don y irlandés howard
fineman ex corresponsal jefe de política
de newsweek sin embargo lo cierto es que
la alegría en el hogar de los valdenses
fuimos rápidamente antes siquiera de
tomar posesión como senador la mujer de
bailén tuvo un accidente de tráfico que
le costó la vida a ella ya su hija y que
también mandó a sus otros dos hijos al
hospital en ese momento se dice que el
bueno de joe estuvo a punto de renunciar
al cargo pero los demócratas le
insistieron querían que siguiera lograr
entrar en el senado ante el rodillo
republicano era un símbolo del cambio y
la nueva generación de políticos que
tendrían que imponerse en la etapa
posterior a mixon la política es una
cuestión de honor personal la palabra de
un hombre es su compromiso dudas tu
palabra y la cumples si haces política
de la manera correcta creo que realmente
puedes mejorar la vida de la gente y la
integridad y es la apuesta mínima para
entrar en
partida joe biden pero sigamos
[Aplausos]
el caso es que en 1987 se convirtió en
el presidente del comité de asuntos
judiciales del senado una etapa que
aprovecho para impulsar una legislación
de mano dura para combatir la
delincuencia el crimen organizado y el
tráfico de drogas una legislación que
contemplaba incluso la pena de muerte lo
que por cierto llama la atención ya que
ahora propone abolir la pena capital
claro que por supuesto del pensamiento
evoluciona por cierto de 1991 también le
tocó conducir las investigaciones del
candidato a juez del supremo clarence
thomas donde sin duda pasar a la
historia su duro tono contra anita hill
la mujer que puso luego confirmado juez
de abuso sexual
[Música]
en cualquier caso lo que no ha cambiado
de su objetivo porque amigos bailén
siempre tuvo en mente un lugar la casa
blanca
joe biden anunció su primera candidatura
a las primarias demócratas en 1987 bien
posicionado por su moderación y con
habilidad para recaudar fondos para su
campaña
bardem sin embargo apenas aguantó dos
meses y medio en la carrera fue acusado
de copiar discursos de políticos
laboristas británicos e incluso del
propio presidente kennedy cuando salió a
la luz pública que ya había tenido
incidentes de plagio durante su etapa
universitaria baiden no le quedó otra
que renunciar
desde luego que en algunos países pues
estas cosas se las toman más en serio
que en otro españa pues no es un buen
ejemplo
[Música]
el caso es que el nuevo siglo le trajo a
byd en la presidencia del poderoso
comité de asuntos exteriores del senado
vaivén había sido un gran defensor de la
intervención militar en los balcanes
contra milósevic y tras los atentados
del 11-s no dudó en trabajar con la
administración republicana de george
walker bush y apoyar el ataque a los
talibanes en afganistán primero y más
tarde al régimen de saddam hussein en
irak aunque más tarde ha reconocido que
se equivocó esto tiene una doble lectura
para los críticos de la guerra una
posición mayoritaria en el partido
demócrata es evidente que se equivocó
hoy que estuvo un lastre para él pero
por otro lado nos muestra un político
que no tiene problemas en trabajar con
los republicanos para llegar a consensos
y eso eso en los tiempos actuales puede
ser un activo muy pero que muy valioso
en 2008 biden volvió a lanzar su
candidatura a las primarias demócratas
pero no pasó de la primera votación
quedó quinto en iowa y vio que no tenía
nada que hacer ante candidatos como
barack obama y hillary clinton pero
obama que apenas llevaba tres años en
washington como senador apostó por la
experiencia de baile en su moderación y
sus conocimientos en política exterior
para ofrecerle formar parte de su equipo
como candidato a vicepresidente
amigos seamos sinceros el perfil de
baile no hubiese sido muy mal visto hace
cuatro años en unas elecciones marcadas
por atrás es decir un empresario popular
que sale la tele de frente a la casta
política que maneja los hilos de
washington pero en noviembre del 2020 en
esta moderación y toda esta experiencia
en la gestión pueden ser su principal
aval en estos tiempos de coronavirus y
crisis
la votación será un auténtico referéndum
sobre trump y la alternativa al actual
inquilino del 1600 de la avenida
pensilvania es el pensilvano joseph
robinet by the junior un político muy
conocido por todos los estadounidenses
que promete dejar atrás la tumultuosa
etapa de la administración trump y que
contará también con el respaldo de los
nostálgicos de obama y por supuesto del
propio expresidente
[Música]
si la muerte de su primogénito la parto
de las presidenciales de 2016 ahora tras
dos intentos fallidos tienen la gran
oportunidad de hacerse finalmente con el
despacho oval claro que hay quien se
pregunta si no le llega un poco tarde a
raiden porque amigos si vence en las
elecciones tomará posesión de su cargo
ni más ni menos que con 78 años setenta
y ocho tacos lo que por cierto
prácticamente coincide con la extra
familia de vida de los eeuu desde luego
se mide por donde se mire es una edad
avanzada claro que lo que hay enfrente
tampoco es que sea muy distinto porque
con 74 años trampa ins junto a reagan el
presidente con mayor edad que busca la
reelección está claro que esto pues no
vale jóvenes pero los tiempos avanzan y
desde luego no penséis que una edad tan
elevada implica forzosamente pues tener
ideas anticuadas a medida que en el
partido demócrata han aparecido
movimientos como decirlo izquierdistas
bailén se ha movido para no quedarse
atrás atentos
hay agua xp
[Música]
la unión hace la fuerza
puede que a priori pues baile no sea el
mejor candidato del mundo solo hay que
verle durante un minuto para saber que
no es el alma de la fiesta ni tampoco el
más indicado para movilizar a los
votantes pero amigos en esta ocasión
todo se ha puesto a su favor la crisis
sanitaria y económica provocada por el
coronavirus han desgastado a trump mucho
más de lo que hasta ahora lo habían
hecho sus habituales excentricidades y
salidas de tono no olvidemos que el
equipo presidencial que asuma el cargo
en enero de 2021 tendrá que hacer frente
a la destrucción de los 42 millones de
empleos que de momento ha provocado el
coronavirus un enorme agujero
presupuestario cortesía de cuatro años
de la administración trump y un panorama
internacional más bien complicado si la
actualidad es terrible para los eeuu
pero amigos para bailén es como decirlo
toda una oportunidad la campaña de by de
encuentra un gancho comercial en una
economía en crisis su trabajo en la
recuperación de 2009 efectivamente la
administración obama nada más llegar se
encontró con los efectos de la gran
recesión y el vicepresidente biden fue
responsable personalmente de administrar
el estímulo lanzado por la casa blanca
un plan de estímulo de casi 800 mil
millones de dólares así que bardem puede
vender que ya se ha enfrentado un
escenario como éste y que las cosas pues
no salieron mal
y desde luego estéis más o menos de
acuerdo con este tipo de políticas no
podemos negar que una experiencia así es
mejor carta de presentación que
prácticamente cualquier discurso que
pueda dar un candidato sobre todo cuando
no eres el más hábil y pues para elegir
las palabras mirad por ejemplo lo que le
pasó al hablar de la violencia contra la
mujer no me dejan
sin este tipo
es verdad yo golpear no había otra
palabra ahora bien cuál es el mayor
problema potencial al que se enfrenta el
ex vicepresidente de obama pues el
efecto hillary clinton es decir que
vuelva a pasar como ya ocurrió en las
elecciones de hillary clinton que una
cuarta parte de los votantes demócratas
no votarán por los demócratas incluso
hasta unos cuantos votarán por trampa
claro que espera un momento porque las
cosas han cambiado mucho desde el 2016
por un lado a día de hoy no se seamos
honestos nada más une al partido
demócrata que el deseo de evitar cuatro
años más de trump y por otro lado porque
bailen podrían llegar a ofrecer una
candidatura más a la izquierda que
hillary clinton ya os lo hemos contado
aquí en visual político el gran éxito de
los sounders warren si jóvenes a lanza
como caso cortés sería mover el partido
demócrata mucho más a la izquierda a
cambio de su apoyo es decir de sus votos
y aparentemente eso es exactamente lo
que ha ocurrido por ejemplo las medidas
de hillary clinton para expandir el
programa sanitario conocido como goma
care tenían un coste de 200 mil millones
de dólares en 10 años pues bien bailén
pone sobre la mesa cuatro veces más
llegando hasta 2 750 mil millones otra
diferencia es que dos demócratas ya no
tachan de radicales iniciativas como por
ejemplo
el salario mínimo un salario mínimo de
15 dólares por horas ya hecho esperar
pero es sólo el comienzo tenemos que
asegurarnos de que cada trabajador
reciba el salario y la dignidad que se
merece y amigos no sé en estos tiempos
de pandemia creo que defender e incluso
ampliar el logo más que puede ser algo
muy popular pero claro acercarse a las
propuestas de sanders requeriría de
varios presupuestos federales para poder
soportar tanto gasto de hecho fue
precisamente en la radicalidad del
candidato socialista de vermont el
motivo por el que los candidatos
demócratas moderados se retiraron de las
primarias para dejar vía libre a baile y
si es verdad las posturas de vaivén
siguen lejos de las de sanders pero es
evidente que se han acercado y la
pregunta es como esperaba y de en
financiar sus promesas es que acaso va a
subir los impuestos pues si los hubiera
eso al menos es lo que ha defendido eso
sí de una forma moderada
by then propone restablecer la tasa
impositiva más alta al 39 6% para
aquellos que ganan más de 400 mil
dólares que tener en cuenta que tras la
bajado al 37% también elevará el
impuesto de sociedades- del 21% al 28%
mientras que antes de trap estaba al 35
en cualquier caso lo que no está en sus
planes es disparar el gasto público
tanto como sanders o adoptar teorías
económicas discutibles que podrían tener
graves consecuencias para la inflación
como la teoría monetaria moderna
no sé tal vez subir los impuestos en
estos momentos de crisis económica pues
quizás no sea la mejor idea del mundo
pero como estáis viendo no son medidas
radicales
[Música]
y por supuesto ya sabéis que una cosa
son las campañas y otra muy distinta a
la presidencia porque puede que en estas
elecciones va a intentar girar con sus
discursos a la izquierdas más de lo que
le gustaría para mantener el voto de los
partidarios de sanders y compañía pero
lo cierto es que este político siempre
representó el centro ideológico de los
demócratas y es que de hecho fue senador
por delaware un estado al que muchos
acusan de ser todo un paraíso fiscal y
del que por cierto os hablamos aquí en
visual política hace poco tiempo os dejo
el vídeo por aquí abajo en la
descripción amigos a lo largo de lo que
ha sido una trayectoria política muy
pero que muy larga bardem ha defendido
posiciones conservadoras en torno al
aborto en algunas cuestiones raciales y
como ya hemos comentado no sólo defendió
sino que propuso la mano dura para
combatir la delincuencia es decir tiene
todos los ingredientes para ser un
candidato de mayorías en los eeuu pero
claro a medida que el centro del partido
se movió hacia la izquierda él también
lo hizo y eso eso nos lleva directamente
a la pregunta clave realmente que
podemos esperar si yo vaivén se
convierte en el 46º presidente de los
eeuu bien atentos
la américa de joe biden
ligera subida de impuestos mucho más
gasto sanitario planes de estímulo e
impulso para elevar el salario mínimo
estas son hasta ahora sus principales
promesas en materia económica pero como
sería en los eeuu de baires pues bien
probablemente su primer objetivo sería
deshacer en pedazos lo que ha supuesto
trump lo que incluiría restaurar el
protagonismo de eeuu entre las
democracias occidentales y una vuelta a
una estrategia multilateral en la escena
internacional seguro seguro que muchos
países asiáticos alegrarían de que
hubiera alguien en washington que por
fin mire más allá de la american first
además bailén también ha hablado ya de
regresar al acuerdo nuclear con en irán
o de suscribir el acuerdo de parís y por
supuesto a nivel interno como os podéis
imaginar pues su elección también
tendría consecuencias
la casa blanca- suavizaría su discurso
frente a la emigración ilegal
de hecho vaivén quiero ofrecer una vía
hacia la ciudadanía para los 11 millones
de sin papeles que ya viven en eeuu pero
tampoco se puede esperar una revolución
si algo demostraron las legislativas de
hace dos años es que para recuperar la
presidencia los demócratas deben atacar
por el centro si va a ir en gana
seguramente dominará la cámara de
representantes pero para tener mayoría
en el senado los demócratas necesitarían
arrebatar 3 de los 23 senadores que los
republicanos pondrán en juego en
noviembre y para tener una supermayoría
que deshaga cualquier bloqueo
necesitarían 13 de esos 23 senadores un
escenario improbable es una debacle
absoluta de trump y del partido
republicano
lo cierto es que aunque pueda
sorprendernos you by te encuentra con
que los republicanos se moderarán tras
una hipotética derrota del actual
presidente además el mismo siempre
destacaba como un político capaz de una
hora demócratas y republicanos para
sacar adelante una legislación que
podría conseguir hoy en día
pues si recordáis el vídeo que dedicamos
a mitt romney el programa maker's
inspiro básicamente en la reforma
sanitaria adaptada entre republicanos y
demócratas en el estado de massachusetts
y si a eso le añadimos el impacto de la
pandemia del coronavirus pues no sé no
parece ciencia ficción pensar que algún
representante de los republicanos se
pudiera sumar a todo un pacto sanitario
federal el plan de atención médica de
joe biden gastaría 750 mil millones de
dólares más en obama care y limitaría la
inflación del precio de los medicamentos
el plan de vaivén consiste en ofrecer
una opción pública en la atención médica
en este sentido como veis iría más allá
de lo que se puso en marcha en
massachusetts ya que ofrecería comprar
un seguro médico del gobierno el
objetivo que millones de estadounidenses
compraban en ese seguro público para
tener un volumen de asegurados lo
suficientemente grande para que esta
opción pública fuera asequible
sostenible y competitiva frente a un
seguro privado además biden quiere
extender el programa público medicare
que garantiza la atención sanitaria
ancianos y discapacitados hasta los 60
años desde los 65 actuales el caso es
que de llevarse a cabo ambas medidas la
futura administración bailén
transformaría la atención médica
estadounidense
[Música]
pero este este no es el único asunto en
el que valve propone un giro de 180
grados pero está tras hayden presenta un
plan de dos millones de dólares para
conseguir electricidad libre de carbono
en 2035 a ver pasar de la nada un plan
climático que invierta 2 billones en
cuatro años no sé es cómo pasar de la
música clásica pues al rock and roll
baiden propone alcanzar una economía con
cero emisiones netas en 2050 y para ello
apuesta por el vehículo eléctrico
proponer las energías limpias y apoyar
la investigación de tecnologías capturen
co2 de la atmósfera pero un momento
porque yo os hemos dicho que vaivén
juega por el centro y aquí se vuelve a
ver perfectamente para que os hagáis una
idea el exvicepresidente de goma no
rechazan la energía nuclear ni tampoco
el fracking así que por qué no podría
lograr nos el apoyo de los republicanos
para un plan federal
[Música]
nadie sabe lo que pueda pasar en un
futuro ni siquiera él
en definitiva extender la atención
médica enfrentarse con estímulos a la
crisis y establecer una política
nacional hacia la descarbonización este
es fundamentalmente el plan baile son
ideas que pueden gustarte más o gustarte
menos pero no son radicales y si luego
tenemos en cuenta su afán por alcanzar
acuerdos con la oposición pues
probablemente el resultado no sería
ningún cambio disruptivo básicamente lo
que va a ir en propone es simple y
llanamente poner orden en washington
pero llegados a este punto turno para ti
que te parecen las promesas electorales
de bailén creéis que se impondrá a trump
dejadme vuestra respuesta en los
comentarios y ya sabéis si el resultado
de este vídeos ha parecido interesante
no olviden el botón de like i
suscribiros a visual polític si aún no
lo habéis hecho una vez más muchas
gracias por estar ahí un saludo y hasta
la próxima
[Música]